une artiste verriez yvelinoise a fait
briller l'Eurovision cette créatrice
passionnée par la couleur et la lumière
à installer son atelier à Houilles en
2004 vitraux vase ou sculpture font
partie de ses réalisations en parallèle
confectionne des trophées pour de
grandes sociétés ou des événements
sportifs approchés par les équipes du
célèbre concours de chant international
elle recevait fin février une commande
pour une remise de prix la prise de
contact c'était par mail comme souvent
avec les entreprises en fait ils avaient
contacté une entreprise apparemment qui
fait des trophées entre guillemets plus
standardisés et qui ont dit non contacté
cette personne puisqu'il faut vraiment
du sur-mesure l'artisan disposait d'un
délai de trois semaines pour achever son
travail dans un premier temps elle
imaginait des œuvres destinées à la
diffusion télévisée mais un atelier
suédois était en charge du projet ses
créations ont finalement servi à un
concours interne entre les salariés de
l'Eurovision la dimension m'a semblé
petite pour un trophée de finale qui
devait se voir sur une estrade de loin
et
le fait qu'il y en ait quatre aussi il
m'a un petit peu intrigué grâce à une
photo du rendu désiré elle s'est lancée
dans la réalisation la créatrice a
dessiné ses propres croquis pour les
quatre micros en verre de 20 cm c'était
chouette à faire c'était bien c'est
toujours un petit peu un challenge parce
qu'il y avait des questions techniques à
résoudre dans un pour que ça ressemble à
ce qu'il souhaitait et puis il y a une
pression parce qu'on dit mince là il
faut pas se louper donc je les ai bien
soignés
surprise par sa récente exposition
médiatique elle reçoit dorénavant de
nombreuses félicitations des habitants
de quoi espérer sa participation au
Trophée de la finale l'année prochaine